angle inclination now what we're going
to work out in a second is this question
so I'm just going to state it to you
real simple but before we answer
directly I've got to sort of take a bit
of a detour ok here's the question have
a look up on the unboard so you can see
it what I'm interested in is measuring
this angle right here what is the angle
that this curve makes with the
horizontal axis there the x-axis K
what's that angle can I measure it
answer yes how do we use all this
information that we've got right now one
of the things we often do in math is we
think about complicated problems messy
problems like gross I don't measure
angles with curved things that's just
weird right it is disgusting
we think about simpler versions of
problems see if we can solve that and
see if some principle there will help us
with a more complicated problem like for
instance imagine if what we could do was
take this weird curvy object and take
instead of that substitute it for a
straight object that behaved just like
this curvy object does if only I could
work out for example what this curve was
like as a straight line and then I can
just measure that angle like I've
measured every other angle in my life
right that's what calculus is all about
so let's have a think about how we're
going to do this ok first underneath
this consider draw me up a are you can
do this one fairly small a Cartesian
plane and then on here instead of this
weird gross looking curvy thing let's
draw just a straight line like so okay
now if what we wanted was the angle of
inclination which is just like an angle
of elevation on this guy it would be
much more straightforward because we can
use all of our knowledge of trigonometry
to help us write if we want to find an
angle all we need is a couple weights in
a right angle triangle and off we go
okay now I admit there's no right angle
triangle there at the moment but it's
not difficult to make one watch if I for
example take anywhere literally anywhere
and draw a vertical line
so and then confident it with a
horizontal line out from the foot of
that tada
ride a go triangle and you can see I've
got a rise over run situation happening
so I want you to tell me in this right
angle triangle here which piece of
trigonometry helps us connect this angle
to these two sides have a look this has
to be tuned right because its opposite
and adjacent see that right opposite
over adjacent so what I can say here is
hold it a second ten theta is opposite
over adjacent rise over run UK with that
but I had a definition for rise over run
we normally call it gradient right so
the letter we usually use for gradient
is M so M equals tan theta right or if
you wanted you could say feed ah that's
the angle I'm after is in most cases tan
inverse of whatever your gradient is so
for instance get your calculator there
let's go in degrees mode for now and if
for example I had a line with a gradient
of one this is not it but just suppose
it had a gradient of one go ahead and
put in theater equals tan inverse of one
what do you get was your calculator
telling in degrees if I had a gradient
of one right and I said oh thinner
equals you should get ten inverse of one
is 45 degrees which makes sense isn't it
you've got a gradient of one every time
you go across one you go up one it's a
45 degree angle make sense this line
doesn't look like one suppose it was two
over one can you do tan inverse of two
for me what's 10ms of 263 does that look
I ball that that looks fine doesn't it
and as you can see if you went ten teams
of three today before and she gets
steeper try to put in something crazy my
tan inverse have like a thousand what
happens what do you get I want an
excellent
eighty nine point five minutes five six
or whatever degrees and minutes well
however you want to do it right so in
other words I'm getting close to
something aren't I there's a limit on
this right you can put tan inverse of a
million I can tell you you're never
gonna get to know you is why not yeah it
would have to be straight up wouldn't it
and you can't measure tan on that sort
of trying so how can I use that alright
because your calculator just fine okay
your calculator was like I've run out of
nines to put here just just have it just
have nine degrees okay all right now how
can I use this to help me well remember
the whole idea of a tangent is if you
look close enough the tangent and the
straight side and the curve are exactly
the same thing so here's what I did
I need the equation or the gradient
really just of the tangent at this point
right how am I going to look at the
picture I'm not going to tell you words
how am I gonna work out the gradient of
that tangent what am I gonna do what I'm
trying to get to is the gradient of this
tangent so I can just draw a triangle in
there it's not measuring things out my
problem don't use unlike with this guy
we're just made up some numbers I
actually can't measure these accurately
I need to use this calculus stuff what
could I do
sorry find the how am I gonna find the
gradient on this that's my question what
do you think is now
haven't we spent most of this morning
developing a way to find gradients of
weird curvy things we're going to use
the difference question the derivative
right so I'm going to help you out a
little bit you can do this by first
principles I'm just going to save you a
little bit of time right now and I'm
going to tell you if that was f of X I'm
going to tell you right now that f dash
will be 2x minus 1 now some of you be
very suspicious say how did you just
work that out
right part of the experience but also
there's a rule in my head that you're
going to learn soon but we're not quite
ready for it ok but that's what are you
are gonna get once you get there how are
you gonna use this what do you do with
2x minus 1 what are we after we're often
angle right to get an angle what do I
need I need I need a gradient right so
how do I use this to find this specific
gradient that I'm off to there it's
another row I've kind of got my graph
already what can I do off this you could
draw this if you like but I would
suggest we don't necessarily need to
write where do I want the gradient yeah
Oh where's the stationary point on this
graph by the way where is it you could
point to it right the stationary point
Santa get hurt it's between the 0 and
the 1 it's right here isn't it
ok which is not the point I'm interested
in yeah
all I want is the gradient of this line
at that point right there at x equals 1
it happens to be X is that right so now
let's work it out F - what 1 equals what
- lots of 1 take away 1 don't forget
your substitution step it does equal 1
ok so then what am I going to do with
that I can say theta equals tan inverse
of 1 which you already worked out it's
45 degrees now go ahead and pop into
desmos this x squared minus x and have a
look at the angle and you'll find sure
enough it's 45 degrees okay